if i work for you
and i'm one of your seventy thousand
dollar your employees at the 200
that's doing 45 million top line revenue
that the company is keeping four and a
half percent four and a half million ten
percent net profit and which you own a
hundred percent of i have to almost
believe
you are jesus or god or somebody of such
power to trust a hundred percent
that you will never flip i have to
almost trust you 100
which then you become like a god figure
and that's a lot of pressure yeah
because most people who are human beings
like you and i
i'm not sure if you've tried to walk on
water i've tried many times i fail every
single time maybe you have i can't so
then then i have to sit there and say
why do i don't trust 100
how do your employees trust you 100
do they kind of see you as a god or how
do they see you like a prophet how do
your employees see you yeah well a
couple things um
because i wanna i wanna answer your
question very specifically about us but
then i wanna make a broader point about
how i think it relates to your you know
you and and other people out there and
people watching us right now
so
i think it just shows again my main
point about how low the bar is
because
we assume
and
frankly pretty much correctly so
that everybody out there that has
ownership and power and those sorts of
things
is going to flip
and basically trade the things that
matter in life
which are
relationships
care
love trust
integrity for the things that don't
matter in life
uh or don't matter as much once you have
enough so money really matters it buys
happiness but it doesn't buy happiness
once you're making a 100 or 150 or 200
000 a year it doesn't buy happiness
certainly when you're making three or
four hundred thousand a year if you make
more than that that's not in general for
most people going to help them and so we
assume
that we are all so greedy and power
hungry and that might be a safe
assumption that might be a safe
assumption and that might be a safe
assumption about me but if it is
then what we need to do is so clear
we need to
have a very high tax rate
with wealthy people
and we need to set rules because soon
with ai and robotics and all that being
private we're going to have these
private armies of security we're going
to have these people that control
a level of power
over all of us
and when you think about automation when
you think about the fact that so many
jobs are going to be eliminated
something like ubi universal basic
income these are the types of uh
solutions that we need to institute and
what i'll say is here's here's my big
failing here's where i really do think i
failed i've allowed myself to become an
excuse for the current system and
perpetuating the status quo because
people can point at my story
and say hey this guy came from very
humble beginnings grew up in idaho look
at what he did but the reality is you're
exactly right because zero big companies
have followed suit and as a result we
have we have been pushing millions of
people into poverty
with our system as set up to basically
reward and not tax the people at the
very top the millionaires and
billionaires and instead be predatory
scammy and tax the people at the bottom
so if we all work together in unison
with one voice to reverse that system
that's really our last line of defen of
of protection overall
and in my company we should institute
some of those rules so that even if i do
turn out to you know go to the dark side
as you say someday like we'll all be
protected
yeah so a couple things one i agree i
think we do need a flat tax it sounds
like you're pitching a flat tax right
now where everybody gets taxed the same
exactly i'm pitching i'm pitching over
10 million i would be super comfortable
with a 50 60 or even 70 percent maybe
even 80 90 percent tax rate i think we
need to get the
house
dan what what countries has a
70 80 90 tax rate ever worked
the united states for one when we
implemented this in the in the 40s and
50s we had two periods in a row that
were about a decade at each where median
incomes doubled after we did it so it's
worked right here in the united states
but currently it's working very well in
places like costa rica in denmark in
norway
90
over over a huge amount yes yeah yeah
but i think you're not talking about
income you're talking about the
elizabeth warren if you're worth over 50
million that's a wealth tax you're
talking about i think we need a goal
i think we need both let me go back to
this so yeah i think uh one on them
trusting you 100 i think you ought to
consider giving 100 of your equity to
all your employees i think you ought to
consider doing that and then also
writing you down and saying in the
constitution before i give the shares to
you if we ever sell and anybody who buys
the company has to be agreeing to the
constitution the profits goes to you but
you cannot philosophically change the
following bylaws so if i'm coming to buy
i may not pay you 40x but i'll pay 10x
and all the employees that own some of
the shares they'll get profit so i think
you ought to consider giving out your
let me but let me just say if you end up
coming to work at gravity payments at
any point
your opinion on this will will it
already matters and i'll already listen
what you say and think about it but if
you worked at gravity and you wanted to
talk to employees about this idea and
see like
do you have support i'd be super excited
about
[Music]